Ron did you get my text no did you get
my emails mm-hmm did you see that i
paged you I did not did you check your
voicemail I didn't we have a criminal
emergency on our hands someone planted a
gateway drug in the community garden
okay call the cops
that'll leak to the press then there'll
be an investigation and they'll find my
fingerprints on the manure and then
we'll lose our funding you don't have
funding and we never will if this gets
out look I will call the cops but just
give me one day to deal with this
internally okay sure thank you
hey listen if this thing blows up I was
never here I have a hernia I've had it
for a while and I've been ignoring it
successfully but this morning I made the
mistake of sneezing yes but as long as I
sit still and don't move my head or
torso I'm good I got this April yeah get
my lunch for me please okay like order
you something no get it from there this
is some kind of weird power trip please
thank you that'll be all you're welcome
[Music]
working late yep
[Music]
you